[Music]
you should know I think it's like a
great example of personal reflection
overcoming struggles moving forward has
your mom listened to it yet like what
does she think yeah I sent it to her the
day or the day after that we wrote it I
know she appreciated it and you know I
put it out on Mother's Day and in honor
of her and yeah it's a more personal
special songs of of my life Morgan's new
album comes two years after his history
making sophomore release dangerous the
double album stanking Bad All I've
rested on you all of this
dangerous spent 60 weeks in the top 10
of the billboard 200 chart more than any
other country album ever beating a
record previously held by Taylor Swift
now the singer is ready to step back
into the spotlight with his new deeply
personal album one thing at a time what
do you hope that they get from it how do
you hope that it affects someone
listening I started the album was born
with a beer in my hand and then you know
we ended it with diamond man that's just
a song that kind of you know hits on the
idea that someone or something you know
gave you a reason to keep living I mean
I was never like thinking I was gonna
die or anything but it's just geared
towards my son you know it gave me a
huge reason to live and a huge reason to
live in a better way
[Music]